>> WASN'T UKRAINE PRESENCE BEEN
ASKING FOR HELP.
>> Interpreter: PROVED THAT
YOU ARE INDEED EUROPEANS, AND
THEN WHITE WILL WIN FOR
THEN LIGHT WILL WIN OVER DEATH,
OVER DARKNESS.
>> WE CARRY THAT LIFE, IT GOT A
STANDING OVATION.
OF THE 676 VOTERS, 637 VOTED TO
PUT THEM IN THE EUROPEAN UNION.
TODAY, WENT ON THE URGING
PRESIDENT BIDEN TO SEND A
MESSAGE TO THE SHIP TONIGHT AT
THE STATE OF THE UNION.
THE FOCUS OF PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
BIG SPEECH SHIFTING, AS FIGHTING
IN UKRAINE GETS MORE HORRIFIC.
ITEM WILL
BIDEN WILL LAY OUT PLANS, AND
ICE AND THEY WILL TALK ABOUT HOW
HE BROKE THE WORLD TOGETHER AND
HOW IT WAS HIS IDEA TO BRING THE
E.U. AND RECONVENED NATO AND SAY
SANCTIONS WILL BE NEXT.
WE WILL WAIT TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
>> Jesse: , WHO ARE RIGHT YOU
DID NOT TAKE THE LEAD.
THERE WILL BE PATRIOTISM IN THE
ROOM.
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE ARE RALLYING TO DEFEND
UKRAINE, GOING AGAINST RUSSIA.
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
THIS HAPPENS ON BIDEN'S WATCH,
AND THE THREAT OF SANCTIONS DID
NOT DETER VLADIMIR PUTIN, AND ON
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE BEING
SPURRED BY THIS REPORT.
THE DOW HAS LOST ABOUT 3,000
POINTS SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
THE YEAR, ALMOST LOST 10%, AND
GAS PRICES ARE HEADED TO $4 A
GALLON.
CAN'T BRAG ABOUT THE ECONOMY,
CAN'T SAY EVERYTHING IS GREAT,
BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LOOK
AT THE GUY AND THINK "WHAT
COUNTRY ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?"
WAGE GAINS GOT DEVOURED BY
INFLATION, PEOPLE ARE WORSE OFF
NOW THAN WHEN HE CAME IN.
HE IS TALKING ABOUT JOB GAINS.
THESE ARE JOBS THAT ARE ADDED
BACK AFTER THEY GOT LOST IN
COVID, SO THAT'S NOT GOING TO
FLY.
SPEAKING OF COVID, HE CAN'T SAY
HE CRUSHED COVID.
EVERYBODY GOT COVID.
[LAUGHTER]
HERD IMMUNITY CRUSHED COVID.
HE ROLLS OUT A BUNCH OF SHOTS,
IT'S TEED UP.
THERE IS SO MUCH A LINGERING
RESENTMENT FOR THE FACT THAT
THIS GUY AND HIS PEOPLE ASKED
KIDS WENT BEYOND WHAT WAS
NECESSARY AND THE FAX FAX
DOMINIC
, VACCINATION MANDATES -- HE
WILL TAP DANCE AROUND THAT,
IGNORE THE BORDER.
I DON'T HAVE OUR EXPECTATIONS.
>> Harold: 120 MILLION PEOPLE
GOT
>> Brian: 120 MILLION PEOPLE
GOT COVID.
JESSE SAYING IT'S A BIG TASK.
WHAT WOULD YOU EMPHASIZE, WHILE
NOT LEAVING REALITY?
>> Harold: THE PRESIDENT HAS
TO BE FRANK WITH THE COUNTRY.
THE STATE OF OUR UNION IS IT'S
BETTER THAN A YEAR AGO, BUT
REMAINS UNSETTLED.
INFLATION, CRIME, COVID, THE
BORDER: ALL THESE ISSUES LOOM
LARGE AND ARE IMPORTANT IN
EVERYDAY TEXTURE AND
CONVERSATION WITH OUR COUNTRY.
WE WOULD BE KIDDING OURSELVES IF
WE DIDN'T RECOGNIZE WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT ON THIS SHOW
IN YOUR SHOW, AND ACROSS THE
NETWORK FOR MANY DAYS.
THE WAR IN UKRAINE, WE'VE BEEN
DRAGGED INTO IT AS PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY HAD SAID.
IT'S CAUSED US ALL TO QUESTION
HOW WE CHOOSE TO DEFEND FREEDOM,
HOW WE CHOOSE TO DEFEND
INDEPENDENCE.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT DWELL
ON IT, BUT HE CERTAINLY SHOULD
TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE IN A WAY
THAT DEMONSTRATES TO AMERICANS
THAT WHEN WE RALLY AROUND A
CAUSE AS AMERICANS, DESPITE OUR
DIFFERENCES COME OF THE THINGS
WE MAY HAVE DISAGREEMENT ABOUT,
WE AGREE ON FREEDOM AND
INDEPENDENCE OF DEMOCRACY.
IT'S UNDER ATTACK NOW.
IT'S UNDER ATTACK IN OUR
HOMELAND IF WE THINK ABOUT HOW
WE ARE GOING TO ADDRESS A
CERTAIN ISSUE.
IF I WAS THE PRESIDENT, I WOULD:
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS TO PUT
A RESET TOGETHER.
ALL THE THINGS WE'VE SEEN SHOULD
MAKE US ALL WANT TO DO WHAT'S
RIGHT FOR EVERY MIDDLE-CLASS
AMERICAN, PARENT, NEIGHBOR.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT THEIR COLOR,
RACIAL BACKGROUND, ECONOMIC
BACKGROUND.
I HOPE THE PRESIDENT ASKS
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS TO
PUSH THE RESET AND DEFENSE
FOREIGN POLICY THAT PROTECTS US
AND HIM AND ADVANCE ECONOMIC
PLAN FOR THE COUNTRY THAT
ENABLES AND EMPOWERS EVERY
AMERICAN.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD DO IF I WERE
HIM WE'D SPEAK IT WITH THIS BE A
UNIFYING MOMENT --
>> Jeanine: NOT A CHANCE.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO CAME IN
AND HASN'T DONE ANYTHING TO
UNIFY.
HAROLD, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, I
HAVE TO DISAGREE.
WE ARE WORSE OFF THAN A YEAR
AGO.
A YEAR AGO WE WERE A NET
EXPORTER OF ENERGY.
A YEAR AGO, WASN'T WHAT THEY
WERE NOW.
A YEAR AGO, INFLATION WASN'T
WHAT IT IS NOW.
WE DID NOT HAVE THE CRIME
PROBLEM WE HAVE NOW AND
IMMIGRATION.
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT HE'S GOT TO
DO.
WHAT HE'S GOING TO DO IS NOT
TALK ABOUT BUILD BACK BETTER
BECAUSE HE KNOWS THAT IT'S GOT A
NEGATIVE CONNOTATION.
HE'S NOT GOING TO MENTION
INFLATION, BECAUSE HE KNOWS THAT
PEOPLE KNOW WHAT IT MEANS AND
IT'S TRANSITORY.
THE PROBLEM IS, WHAT I WANT TO
KNOW IS WHY IS THE ENERGY SECTOR
EXEMPT FROM THE SANCTIONS?
WHY ARE WE ESSENTIALLY FUNDING
THE RUSSIAN WAR ON UKRAINE?
STOP WITH THIS NONSENSE "THIS IS
AN ATTACK AGAINST DEMOCRACY" I'M
TIRED OF MEANINGLESS WORDS.
I'M TIRED OF HEARING IT.
WE ARE FUNDING THE WAR IN
RUSSIA.
YESTERDAY, JEN PSAKI, AND TODAY,
SENATOR WARNER, A DEMOCRAT, BOTH
SAID "IF WE CANNOT TURN ON THE
KEYSTONE PIPELINE, IT WOULD TAKE
YEARS BEFORE WE SEE THE
BENEFITS."
HOGWASH.
LAST YEAR, WE SAW THE BENEFITS
OF BEING INDEPENDENT AND WITH
OUR OWN ENERGY.
STOP WITH THE NONSENSE, GIVE US
THE STRAIGHT TALK.
>> Brian: JODY HAS A DIFFERENT
TAKE.
[LAUGHTER]
THOUGHT I HAD BROKEN THIS UP
DIFFERENT.
DANA, YOU PUT THESE SPEECHES
TOGETHER.
JOE MANCHIN SAID" WOULD STOP
BUYING RUSSIAN OIL AND GAS AND
START PRODUCING OUR OWN."
I BELIEVE HE'S STILL A DEMOCRAT.
>> I BELIEVE HE
>> Dana: I BELIEVE HE IS.
IF HE SAYS BUILD BACK BETTER, I
WOULD BE SURPRISED.
HOLES FROM ABC AND "CBS NEWS"
HAVE SHOWN THE PRESIDENT AT
ABOUT A 37%-38% APPROVAL RATING
IS NEGATIVE FOR PRESIDENT GOING
INTO A STATE OF THE UNION, WHICH
IS SUPPOSED TO TALK ABOUT ALL
YOUR COMPLIMENTS.
THINK FOR A BIG APPLAUSE LINE, A
STANDING OVATION.
YOU KNOW WHERE HE'S GOING TO GET
THEM IS AT THE FRONT AND BACK OF
THE SPEECH WHEN HE TALKS ABOUT.
HE HAS A TOP DOMINIC A LOT HE
WILL TO GET TO.
HE IS A PRINT NOMINEE WILL BE
THERE, AND WILL BE A BIG WOMAN,
A HISTORICAL NOMINATION.
SHE WILL HAVE HER CHANCE TO GET
APPLAUSE.
SHE WILL BEGIN TO HAVE HER
HEARING -- AND HOPEFULLY, FROM
HER POINT OF VIEW, WILL TRY TO
WIN SOME REPUBLICANS OVER AS
WELL.
HE'S NOT TRYING TO TALK ABOUT A
LOT OF THINGS.
NOBODY HEARS DOMINIC WANTS TO
HEAR ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE, BUT
THEY WILL TALK ABOUT IT.
IT'S GOING TO BE HARD TO HOLD
PEOPLE'S ATTENTION.
IT TAKES MONTHS TO PUT TOGETHER
A SPEECH AND THEN, EVERYONE
ACROSS THE GOVERNMENT IS TRYING
TO GET THEIR PET PROJECT
MENTIONED.
I NOTICED THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
THE INTERIOR, THE SECRETARY PUT
OUT A STATEMENT YESTERDAY ABOUT
HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO DEAL WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT IS NOT A NONIMPORTANT ISSUE,
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE AN OFF RAMP
FOR PEOPLE.
YOU CAN'T IMAGINE HOW FOCUSED
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE ON
ENERGY POLICY, AND WHAT THAT'S
DOING TO INFLATION.
SHE WILL
ALSO WANT TO TALK
HE WILL ALSO WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN.
WHAT AMERICANS HAVE DONE, THE
MAJORITY OF THEM HAVE CONNECTED
THE EXTRA MONEY GOING INTO THE
SYSTEM THAT HELPED RAISE -- ON
EVERYTHING ELSE.
A LOT OF THINGS HE WOULD WANT TO
TALK ABOUT IS ACCOMPLISHMENTS
ARE VULNERABILITIES, EXCEPT,
PERHAPS, THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL.
>> YOU HAVE A REBUTTAL, THEN A
REBUTTAL TO THE REBUTTAL.
GOING TO COME OUT, CALL OUT THE
PRESIDENT.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT